SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING IF ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
COME TO ROOM 2100 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM FOR HEARING I
WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED. WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, AND THERE ARE NO CONSENT
ITEMS SINCE WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. ONCE WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
MEMBERSHIP WE'RE READY TO HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR, SENATOR
BLAKE SPIRIT. I SEE YOU'RE HERE.
YOU CAN PRESENT YOUR BILL. SB
689. HELLO. HELLO GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TODAY. UM I AM, PLEASE. MY NAME
IS SENATOR CATHERINE BLAKE SPEAR
AND I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
689, WHICH WILL REDUCE
UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN BUILDING
BIKE LANES ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE AND ALREADY DEVELOPED
AREAS. DURING MY TIME AS THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF ENCINITAS,
WE BUILT SEVERAL PROTECTED BIKE
LANE PROJECTS, AMENDING THE
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM. OTHER
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE LCP AND
COMMISSIONING THE REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL TRAFFIC STUDIES
RESULTED IN A DIFFICULT,
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING AND AT
TIMES NEEDLESSLY CONTENTIOUS
PROCESS TO BUILD A BIKE LANE,
MAKING BIKING EASIER, SAFER AND
MORE COMMON IS A CRITICAL
ELEMENT AND REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS WE
CONFRONT THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO US AS
POLICYMAKERS TO ENSURE GOOD
GOVERNANCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND ELIMINATE ANY BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLES THAT MAY PREVENT OR
PROLONGED PROJECTS THAT PROVIDE
A NET POSITIVE TO SOCIETY AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT. MY TEAM AND I
HAVE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION OVER MORE THAN A YEAR
ABOUT THIS EFFORT ABOUT HOW TO
MORE QUICKLY AND EASILY BUILT BY
CLEAN AND NOW WE ARE ON THE SAME
PAGE ABOUT HOW TO ACHIEVE THIS
OBJECTIVE. SO THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS. FIRST IT STATES THAT A
NEW TRAFFIC STUDY, WHICH CAN BE
COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING IS NOT
NECESSARY FOR AN LCP AMENDMENT
WHEN A LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
CONVERTING AN EXISTING MOTORIZED
VEHICLE LANE INTO A DEDICATED
BICYCLE LANE. AND SECONDLY, IT
ALLOWS FOR THE AMENDMENT TO THE
LCP TO BE PROCESSED UNDER A DE
MINIMUS EXEMPTION WHEN THE
COASTAL COMMISSION'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DETERMINES THAT THIS IS
WARRANTED. SP 689 IS A GOOD
GOVERNANCE BILL THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
RESPONSIVENESS OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF BIKE LANES WITH ME TODAY, I'M
PLEASED TO WELCOME TO THE
MICROPHONE, MORE RED TOP FROM
TOP STRATEGIES. SHE'S HERE IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO. I'M SO SORRY, AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO LEAD WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT AND DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS, EACH SIDE WILL BE
FUNDED TWO MINUTES EACH FOR
THEIR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. MISS TOP YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I AM WIRETAP HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
HAPPY TO BE HERE AS A SPONSOR OF
THE MEASURE. SP 689, AS WE HEARD
IS INTENDED TO REDUCE AND
UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
BICYCLE SAFETY TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COAST. THIS BILL WILL MAINTAIN
IMPORTANT COASTAL PROTECTIONS
AND ENSURE BROAD COASTAL ACCESS,
BUT REPLACES THE CURRENT
BURDENSOME AND TIME CONSUMING
COASTAL COMMISSION PROCESS WITH
ONE THAT IS STREAMLINED AND
PURPOSEFUL. THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS BEGUN TO
MANDATE THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AMEND THEIR LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAMS FOR PROJECTS THAT
MERELY RE STRIPE THE ROAD
CONSTRUCT THE ROAD FOR CONSTRUCT
CONTRACT CONGESTION REDUCTION
PURPOSES. LCP AMENDMENT PROCESS
CAN TAKE 18 MONTHS TO TWO YEARS
TO COMPLETE AND, OF COURSE, COST
CITY RESOURCES. THESE
RESTRICTING PROJECTS DO NOT
EXTEND BEYOND THE CURRENT RIGHT
OF WAY. OR HAVE ANY IMPACT ON
SURROUNDING FLORA OR FAUNA.
IMPROVING OUR BIKE LANE NETWORK,
ESPECIALLY ALONG THE CURVED
COASTAL ROADS WILL ALSO LEAD TO
BETTER BIKE SAFETY AND LIKELY
RESULT IN FEWER FATALITIES ON
OUR COASTAL ROADS. SP 689 IS
INTENDED TO REDUCE THE
UNNECESSARY, COSTLY AND TIME
CONSUMING BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES,
WHICH HAVE PREVENTED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LIKE THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO. TO PURSUE COMMON
SENSE TRAFFIC IMPROVEMENTS. THIS
MEASURE WILL IMPROVE TRAFFIC
SAFETY FOR ALL MODES AND
ASSISTANT MEETING OUR CLIMATE
AND TRAFFIC SAFETY GOALS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR BLAKE.
SIR DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TODAY? WE
DO NOT OKAY. WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ANY LEAD. WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL?
NO. ONE WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY
OTHER SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ME TO TESTIMONY.
ANYBODY HERE? WANT TO SPEAK OUT
IN SUPPORT? OR OPPOSITION OF
THIS FILM, PLEASE, JUST STATE
YOUR POSITION AND AFFILIATION
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. GOOD
MORNING, SHARON GONSALVES ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
SAYING NO ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM.
I THINK WE NOW HAVE QUORUM SO
WELL. LET'S BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
VOTE. LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
REALLY QUICKLY. ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
MEN HERE IN HERE. SEYARTO. ALAN
ALAN HERE, BECKER BECKER HERE,
DELI. GROVE. GROVE HERE, HER
TAITO. LAIRD LAIRD HERE, LIMÓN
PADILLA HERE, STERN. OKAY QUORUM
IS ESTABLISHED. UM SO WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR WITNESSES WILL
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
DESK. YOU ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THE MEASURES? SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR CHAIRMAN,
JUST TO CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR
ON A THOUGHTFUL BUILDING, BUT
THE MINIMUS ROUTE IS TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE HERE AT THE RIGHT
TIME. I'M HAPPY TO MOVE. WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. I ALSO JUST
WANT TO MENTION I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MULTIMODAL
TRANSPORTATION IS VERY IMPORTANT
. I READ MY ELECTRIC SCOOTER UP
AND DOWN IN SACRAMENTO. RIDE MY
BICYCLE IN IRVINE, AND I THINK
WE NEED SAFER PASSAGEWAYS FOR
OUR DIFFERENT MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. SO, UM WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. AND THE
MOTION IS THIS IS DUAL REFERRED
TO TRANSPORTATION SO THE MOTION
IS DUE PAST THE TRANSPORTATION.
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MEN, MEN, I SEYARTO
ALAN ALAN I. BECKER BECKER. I
DOLLY. GROVE. GROVE KNOW HER
TAITO. LAIRD I LIMÓN PADILLA
PADILLA, I STERN. THANK YOU.
PRESENTING. OR OH, I'M SORRY.
THE VOTE IS 51 WILL LEAVE THAT
ON CALL. ALRIGHT. THE NEXT
PHYLLIS ISN'T RIGHT. S P 559 BY
A GUY NAMED SENATOR, MAN. UM
PASSES OVER TO YOU, SENATOR
LORD. HMM. HMM. GREAT. YOU MAY
PROCEED. DO WE HAVE? FUNNY CIDE.
CHAIR NUMBERS HERE TO PRESENT SP
559, WHICH SEEKS TO END THE
DANGEROUS PRACTICE OF OFFSHORE
OIL DRILLING IN CALIFORNIA STATE
WATERS. AS YOU ALL ARE AWARE IN
OCTOBER, 2021, A MAJOR OIL SPILL
TOOK PLACE OFF THE COAST OF
ORANGE COUNTY, HUNTINGDON BEACH
IN MY DISTRICT. APPROXIMATELY
25,000 GALLONS OF OIL SPILLED
INTO HER COASTAL WATERS, KILLING
FISH AND BIRDS, FORCING BEACH
CLOSURES AND DEVASTATING THE
LOCAL ECONOMY. HE TOOK NEARLY
1500 PEOPLE AND ALMOST $3
MILLION IN STATE FUNDING TO
CLEAN UP THE SPILL. FIRST
RESPONDERS REPORTED THAT THE OIL
LEAK STRETCHED OVER HUNDREDS OF
MILES FROM THE COAST OFF OF
HUNTINGDON BEACH ALL THE WAY
PAST THE MEXICAN BORDER. JUST AS
COASTAL BUSINESSES STARTED TO
RECOVER FROM THIS EVENT. TWO
MONTHS LATER. PLATFORM EVA
EXPERIENCE TO LEAK. MANY OF
THESE REFINERIES ARE ENTERING 60
. YEARS OF OPERATION, NOT
REFINERIES, THESE PLATFORMS AND
THEY'VE OUTLASTED THEIR INTENDED
LIFESPANS AND ARE TICKING TIME
BOMBS. THERE IS LITTLE INCENTIVE
FOR THE REMAINING WILDCAT
OPERATORS TO INVEST IN THESE
REINVEST IN THESE PLATFORMS, AND
AS SUCH, THEY CONTINUE TO POSE A
GRAVE THREAT TO OUR MARINE
ECOSYSTEMS ARE COASTAL
ECONOMIES. IN OUR STATE ECONOMY.
IT'S TIME TO STOP THIS POLLUTION
WHERE IT STARTS AND PUT THE
STATE ON TO TRANSITION PATH
TOWARDS MORE SUSTAINABLE
RESOURCES PROCUREMENT. SB 559
WOULD IMPACT JUST THREE OFFSHORE
OIL AND GAS PLATFORMS. EVA AND
ME AND ESTHER. ALL OF WHICH
CURRENTLY OPERATE OFF THE COAST
OF ORANGE COUNTY. THESE
PLATFORMS WERE ALL CONSTRUCTED
BETWEEN THE YEARS 1963 AND 1985,
AND THEY ARE THE LAST REMAINING
OIL PLATFORMS STILL OPERATION IN
STATE WATERS. THIS BILL WOULD
DIRECT THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO BEGIN NEGOTIATIONS
FOR VOLUNTARY RELINQUISHMENT OF
THE LEASES THAT AUTHORIZED OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION IN STATE
WATERS. AND IF NEGOTIATIONS ARE
NOT REACHED BY THE END OF 2026
WOULD REQUIRE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO TERMINATE THE
LEASES IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
ENDING OFFSHORE PRODUCTION IN
STATE WATERS AS WE MOVE TOWARDS
A CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. NOT ONLY
DO WE OWE THIS TO OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES, WE OWE IT TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO MEET OUR ENERGY
TARGETS, AND AT THE SAME TIME,
SAFEGUARD OUR PRECIOUS MARINE
ECOSYSTEMS AND OUR BEACHES. AS
CALIFORNIANS WE IDENTIFY NOT
JUST WITH OUR ECONOMIES, BUT OUR
CULTURAL IDENTITY LIES WITH OUR
COASTS. AND UM, I THINK THIS IS
A LONG PAST DUE, SO I'M JOINED
TODAY BY CREEP CHRISTINA,
SCARING WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY, TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND UH, YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHRISTINA SURRENDERED
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY WITH THANKS TO THE
AUTHOR AND TO THE COMMITTEE. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE TERMINATION
OF OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS LEASES.
CALIFORNIA OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION IS AT THE END OF ITS
LIFE CYCLE IN THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO MINIMIZE THE DAMAGE
THIS INDUSTRY DOES ON ITS WAY
OUT THE DOOR. OPERATORS UNDER
THESE DECADES OLD LEASES LONG
AGO RECOUP THEIR INVESTMENTS
INDUSTRY PROFITED HANDSOMELY
WHILE EXTERNALIZING, THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH HARMS
UPON CALIFORNIA'S PEOPLE, PLACES
AND BIODIVERSITY. WE APPLAUD THE
LEGISLATURE'S PUSH TO FINALLY
END DESTRUCTIVE FOSSIL FUEL
PRODUCTION IN OUR IN OUR STATE
WATERS. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO GIVE THE
COMMISSION TOOLS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER LEE SEES ARE OWED ANY
COMPENSATION AT THESE LEASES. NO
COMPENSATION IS WARRANTED WHERE
THE COMMISSION IS ACTING TO
ABATE ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLIMATE
HARM CAUSED BY FOSSIL FUEL
PRODUCTION AT THESE LEASES. OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION IS LONG
POLLUTED AND DISRUPTED POSTAL,
MARINE ENVIRONMENT IMPOSING
CONTINUING RISKS ON COASTAL
COMMUNITIES, ECONOMIES, HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTS. THESE LEASES
IN THE REMAINING ACTIVE OFFSHORE
PLATFORMS POSE ONGOING AND
UNACCEPTABLE THREATS TO THE $44
BILLION COASTAL ECONOMY AND
CONFLICT WITH CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
POLICY. THESE LEASES ARE FAR
BEYOND THEIR EXPECTED LIFE. MUCH
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS OLD,
CORRODED, ULTRA HAZARDOUS AND
LONG PAST ITS LIFESPAN, THE COST
TO DECOMMISSION AND REMOVE THE
PLATFORMS AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO REMEDIATE
THE AREA WHICH ARE THE LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE INDUSTRY
LIKELY FOR EXCEED ANY FUTURE
PROFITS FROM THEIR CONTINUED
OPERATION. IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THESE
POLLUTERS PAY FOR THEIR CLEANUP.
AND DON'T DUMP THEIR COSTS ON
CALIFORNIANS. THIS DEFINING
DECADE IN OUR CURRENT FISCAL
ISSUES DEMAND AND THIS
LEGISLATION OFFERS BOLD,
SIGNIFICANT NEAR TERM ACTION TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CRISES,
ENABLING ITS LEADERSHIP AND
CONTINUED PUSH TO A SUSTAINABLE,
JUST AND PROSPEROUS FUTURE OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION IS A PUBLIC
NUISANCE THAT HAS NO PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. THERE'S NO
SAFE OR CLEAN WAY TO DRILL FOR
OIL. NEW JERSEY, OREGON AND
VIRGINIA HAVE ALL BANNED
OFFSHORE DRILLING IN STATE
WATERS. IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
TO PASS THIS BILL AND PROTECT
ITS WATERS AND COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU AND RESPECT. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, MR ORANGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, UM AND I
HAVE LISTED NO OTHER PRIMARY
WITNESS, SO THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY TO COME
TO THE MICROPHONE AND DO AN
ESSENCE OF ME TO SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WISHES TO ADD
THEIR NAMES AND SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL? SAYING NO. ONE NO. ONE
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION AND THE
SAME RULE APPLIES. WE HAVE UP TO
TWO MINUTES. UM FOR THE WEED
WITNESS. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
AND MR CHAIR. UH, AS WE DID LAST
YEAR. MY NAME IS PAUL D'ORO,
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION. WE DO
HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE,
UH, ABOUT THIS BILL IN AND THAT
IS THE MANDATORY TERMINATION OF
OFFSHORE LEASES IN STATE WATERS.
WE BELIEVE WOULD BE A TAKING. AH
AND IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL, THE
BUILDERS WOULD RESULT IN
SUBSTANTIAL STATE LIABILITY AS A
RESULT OF THAT. AH! WE IS SHARED
AGREEMENT BETWEEN AN OPERATOR
OPERATORS IN THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS NOTHING THAT WE
WOULD WE WOULD OPPOSE. IT'S THE
MANDATORY NATURE OF THIS BASED
ON A STUDY, WHICH WAS IN A BILL
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THAT STATE
LANDS COMMISSION IS CONCLUDING
NOW. WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT IS
INADEQUATE TOOL TO NEGOTIATE A
WHAT IS A PRIVATE AGREEMENT AND
WHAT OUR LEASES THAT GO IN
PERPETUITY. FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THE BILL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. THIS WOULD BE
THE OPERATOR. UH, THIS WOULD BE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR, UM ANYONE
TO JOIN IN A ME TO OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL SER ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO DO THAT? SEEING NO.
ONE. BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. AND JUST BEFORE
WE GET COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. LET ME ASK, ARE YOU,
UM, ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PROBABLY REQUIRED FROM
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE? YES
I MEANT TO SAY THIS IN MY
CLOTHES, BUT I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. OKAY
GREAT. NOW WE'LL MOVE. TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I AM JUST GUESSING
SENATOR GROVE HAS A COMMENT. UH,
AYE. I DO HAVE A COMMENT AND, UM
, I KNOW YOU GUYS GET TIRED OF
HEARING IT, BUT I JUST DESPISE
THE HYPOCRISY. WE IMPORT 1.8
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL EVERY
SINGLE DAY THAT WE CONTINUE TO
USE HIS CALIFORNIANS. WE IMPORT
THEM FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
SHIPS THAT HAVE LEAKAGE ALL
ACROSS THE ECOSYSTEM WHEN THEY
COME HERE TO BRING CALIFORNIA'S
OIL THAT CALIFORNIANS USE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES. ECUADOR UM,
THERE'S BLANK FLAGSHIPS OR
FLAGSHIPS. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT FLAGS. THERE'S A THERE'S
PROOF THAT WE GET OIL FROM IRAN
THAT FUNDS WARS WE UM, THERE'S.
WHERE THE AMAZON COLOMBIA IF YOU
LOOK AT THE SECRETARIES OF
ENERGY'S WEBSITE, IT WILL SHOW
YOU THAT WE GET A LOT OF OUR OIL
FROM FOUR CALIFORNIANS FROM
WHERE THE RAINFOREST IS WHERE WE
BULLDOZE DOWN THE RAINFOREST.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT BRINGING
THOSE SHIPS HERE. THERE'S NO
REGULATORY PROCESS FOR THESE
FOREIGN OPERATORS. WE LEARNED
LAST YEAR THAT THEY JUST SIMPLY
SUBMIT A LETTER TO, UH, CARB AND
SAYS THIS IS THE CARBON
EMISSIONS THAT WE ADMITTED. UH
AND SOMETIMES IT'S 26 MILLION
METRIC TURNS PER TRIP. FROM
THESE FOREIGN COUNTRIES TO GET
US THERE, AND THEY JUST SAY,
JUST TRUST US. THIS IS THE
EMISSIONS THAT WE HAVE ADMITTED,
AND THEY'RE COMPLETELY OFF AND
VERY LOW. UM I AGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. I MEAN, IF
YOU OWN YOUR HOME, OR YOU HAVE A
INDEFINITE LEAST ON YOUR
PROPERTY, AND THE GOVERNMENT
COMES IN AND SAYS WE'RE GOING TO
VOLUNTARILY MAKE YOU NEGOTIATE
WITH US. AND IF WE DON'T LIKE
YOUR NEGOTIATION, WE'RE JUST
GOING TO STOP YOUR LEASE. THAT'S
NOT THAT IS A TAKING UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION AND WHEN WE GET
SWORN INTO OFFICE WE ALWAYS
RAISE OUR RIGHT HAND AND SWEAR
TO DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES AND CALIFORNIA
AND IT'S AND WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
SUPPORT THAT. AND THIS IS AN ODD
THIS BILL CREATES A TAKING UNDER
THAT CONSTITUTION, AND IT WILL
BE CHALLENGED. UM, BUT THAT'S
JUST A RESOURCE AND IT IT THAT
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE TO FIGHT THAT
CHALLENGE ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT. AND WHEN
CALIFORNIA LOSES, THAT'S
EXTENSIVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE REIMBURSED
OPERATORS. IT'S A TAKING WHEN
YOU DON'T ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE
PERMITS SPECIFICALLY LIKE IN
CURRENT COUNTY, WHEN AND I KNOW
THIS IS SEPARATE FROM YOUR BILL,
BUT THEY DON'T DENY THE PERMITS.
THEY DON'T DENY THE PERMITS.
THEY JUST LET IT SIT FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS BECAUSE IT'S
A TAKING, YOU'RE NOT ALLOWING
THEM TO USE THEIR PROPERTY. WHEN
WE CONSUME THIS, AND IT MAKES
OUR LIFE NOT A THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY AND WE CONSUME OIL EVERY
SINGLE DAY, AND I KNOW YOU RIDE
A SCOOTER. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
OIL AND PETROLEUM PRODUCTS AND
THAT SCOOTER THAT YOU WOULD NEED
TO MAKE THAT SCOOTER. GO UM SO
JUST MY COMMENTS ON OPPOSING THE
BILL FOR OBVIOUS REASONS,
BECAUSE NUMBER ONE, THE OATH
THAT WE TOOK AND NUMBER TWO.
IT'S VERY HYPOCRITICAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IS
ANYBODY GOING TO PROPOSE ANY
ACTION? YEAH. WE NEED A MOTION.
WELL I'M LOOKING TO SEE US.
SOMEBODY FINALLY ASKED TO BE
RECOGNIZED, SENATOR BECKER. I
MOVED ON. OKAY? UH WE HAVE A
MOTION. UH, SENATOR MIN. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. UM JUST TO ADDRESS THE
TAKING QUESTION. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. SENATOR GROVE
AND THANK YOU YOUR COMMENTS,
PAUL. UM IF AT FIRST I WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING A BILL
LOOKING INTO THE CLIMATE, CARBON
EMISSIONS CREATED BY OIL
IMPORTED UNITED STATES, SO
HOPEFULLY SOMEONE MIGHT TAKE
THAT UP. THAT'D BE A GREAT DEAL.
15 TAKE A LOOK AT THAT ON THE
TAKINGS ISSUE. ARBIL PRETTY GOOD
WITH THE AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY
CONTEMPLATES THAT AND SO TAKING
IS NOT ON ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
UNLESS IT'S NOT ACCOMPANIED BY
FAIR COMPENSATION. AND SO OUR
BILL EXPRESSLY STATES THAT IF
WARRANTED, IF IT IS DETERMINED,
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT ARE TAKING HAS
OCCURRED, FAIR COMPENSATION
WOULD BE PROVIDED SO WITH THAT,
I THINK IT DOES SATISFY
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE FIFTH AMENDMENT, AND
THE 14TH AMENDMENT, UM, BUT
HAPPY TO DISCUSS. I THINK
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL IS ALSO
FOUND THAT TO THE CASE AS WELL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY. IT'S A
$44 BILLION ANNUAL COASTAL
ECONOMY AND THAT THAT IS WHAT
THE COASTAL ECONOMY GENERATES
FOR THE STATE, AS MY WITNESS
STATED, AND THAT IS UNDER THREAT
, AND SO EVEN IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE IN CLIMATE CHANGE, AND I
HOPE EVERYONE UP HERE RECOGNIZES
THE CRITICAL MOMENT THAT WE'RE
IN AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CARBON EMISSIONS, THE RISK
REWARD OF OFFSHORE DRILLING,
GIVEN THE THREAT OF POSES TO
THIS VIBRANT COASTAL ECONOMY,
THAT IS THAT THE LIFE IN ESSENCE
OF OUR CULTURAL IDENTITY AS
CALIFORNIANS. I THINK IT'S NOT
WORTH FIT AND I THINK, UM, I
HOPE YOU WILL AGREE, SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS POLICE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS MEN, MEN, I
SEYARTO ALAN ALAN I BECKER
BECKER. I DALLI DALLI. NO GROVE
GROVE KNOW HER TANO LAIRD. I
LIMÓN. MADEA MADEA. I STERN. AND
UH, SENATOR SCENARIOS HERE,
SANDOR STARRED. OH NO ACCOUNT.
THAT'S FIVE. EYES THREE KNOWS
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL. AND
IN THE CHAIR COMES AROUND FOR
THE NEXT BILL. THANK YOU. OKAY?
UM, ARE. MANY ARE THIRD BILL AND
FINAL BILL TODAY IS SP 571 BY
SENATOR ALLEN, SENATOR ALLEN.
MAY PROCEED. WELL, THANK YOU, MR
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS LET ME START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR ITS WORK ON THE BILL.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. THIS
BILL. UH WITH THE COMMUNITY
AMENDMENTS CHARGES, THE STATE
BOARD OF FORESTRY WITH THE TASK
OF PRESENTING A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM MINIMUM EGRESS AND EGRESS.
ROUTE STANDARDS. OUR STATE FINDS
OURSELVES OURSELVES AT A REAL
CHALLENGE IN THIS SPACE. WE
CONTINUE TO NEED TO DEVELOP, UH
ADDITIONAL HOUSING, BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO BE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS WITH THE NECESSARY
CONSIDERATION FOR THE KINDS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL THREATS THAT SOME
AREAS POSE FOR DEVELOPMENT. LAST
YEAR, THE BOARD RELEASED ITS
MINIMUM FIRE SAFETY REGULATIONS.
BUT THOSE REGULATIONS DO NOT
CONSIDER A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
INGRESS AND EGRESS ROUTES
REQUIRED A NEW DEVELOPMENTS. AND
I THINK WE'VE SEEN UM YOU KNOW
ALL OVER THE STATE. I KNOW IT'S
CERTAINLY IN MY IN SOME AREAS OF
MY DISTRICT, EXISTING EVACUATION
ROUTES WOULD BE STRETCHED VERY
THIN IN THE EVENT OF A MAJOR
WILDFIRE EMERGENCY AND NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN THOSE AREAS
WITHOUT THE INCLUSION OF
ADDITIONAL NECESSARY EVACUATION
ROUTING COULD BE DEADLY. WE
CERTAINLY SEEN UH. WITH THAT
LOOKS LIKE IN IN IN SOME PARTS
OF THE STATE WITH SOME OF THE
TRAGEDIES WE'VE HAD OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS. SO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SEEK A VALUABLE STEP
FORWARD IN THIS AREA BY HAVING
THE BOARD STUDY THIS ISSUE WHILE
CONSIDERING IMPORTANT AND
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS, SUCH AS
THE SIZE OF THE DEVELOPMENT. IF
IT WOULD CONTAIN VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS, TRAFFIC IMPACT AND
OTHERS. AND, AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS, THIS BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AS WE CONTINUE ENGAGING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
NUANCED BUT IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND
I COMMIT TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE. AND KEEPING YOU
CLOSELY APPRISED OF DEVELOPMENTS
ON THIS BILL SHOULD IT PASSED
TODAY SO HERE TO TESTIFY AND
SUPPORT AS MATTHEW BAKER FROM
THE PLANNING CONSERVATION LEE?
THANK YOU, UM MOVE ON THE LEAD
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES, SIR. GOOD MORNING
TEAR AND SOME OF YOURS. MATTHEW
BAKER, POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
PLAYING CONSERVATION LEAGUE. I
DON'T THINK WITH THIS COMMITTEE
I HAVE TO GO INTO THE OTHER
REASONS WHY WE NEED TO DO BETTER
PLANNING AND HIGH RISK FIRE
AREAS, BUT THE MOTIVATION OF 571
WAS SIMPLY THAT YOU KNOW, RATHER
THAN ASK THE QUESTION OF WHERE
WE'RE NOT. YOU CAN BUILD. UM YOU
IF YOU DO BUILD, YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO GET DEMONSTRATE THAT YOU
CAN GET PEOPLE OUT SAFELY AND
COMMON SENSE IDEA THAT YOU KNOW,
WILL SAVE LIVES AND OUR ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR WAS MUCH MORE
PRESCRIPTIVE. UM THIS PROPOSAL,
YOU KNOW THAT MET A LOT OF
CONCERNS THAT PRESCRIPTION AND
THIS PROPOSAL IN TURN, UM, WOULD
LEAVE IT TO THE AGENCY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
STANDARDS ARE IN THIS SPACE.
WHICH MAY BE APPROPRIATE PLACE
TO DO SO. BUT WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THIS APPROACH TO
AND WE ARE VERY COMMITTED. I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR IS TO
WORKING WITH ALL INTERESTED IN
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE RIGHT
POLICY IS IN THIS SPACE AND TO
START SAVING LIVES. UM WE ASKED
MORE THAN ANYTHING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY, SO WE CAN CAN
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SAYING NO
OTHER LEAD WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
. LET'S HEAR FROM ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM WANTS TO GIVE ME TWO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ALRIGHT SAYING NO ONE. DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? THAT WE SEE TOO. ARE
YOU ALSO WE WITNESSED AN
OPPOSITION. SO WE HAVE TO YOU
GUYS. OKAY HUMANITY EACH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SILVIO FERRARI
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION, SO WE HAVE
AN OPPOSED POSITION ON THE
PREVIOUS BILL. RECOGNIZING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE FORTHCOMING,
THE WORK THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
DONE TO PAIR THIS BACK. WE ARE
VIEWING IT RIGHT NOW. IN THIS
MOMENT AS REALLY A WORK IN
PROGRESS, IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE IS ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. SO I THINK WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD OVER THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES. FIGURE OUT HOW TO, YOU
KNOW, REALLY CRAFT SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE WIN WIN FOR
EVERYBODY. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. PROCEED. JENNIFER SPEC ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. WE ARE
ELATED TO SEE THE NEW AMENDMENTS
IN THE BILL. WE HAD PREVIOUSLY
OPPOSED THE INTRODUCED DROP TO
THE BILL, AS AS WE FOUND IT TO
BE A LITTLE BIT ONEROUS TO HAVE
THE BUILDER BE HANDLING THE
PLANNING IN THAT PARTICULAR
ACTIVITY WITH THAT SAID WE WERE
FORMALLY REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
. SORRY WE DIDN'T GET A LETTER
IN TIME DUE TO THE CROSSING OF
THE AMENDMENTS AFTER THE LETTER
DEADLINE. WILL FORMALLY SEND A
LETTER AFTER THIS HEARING. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE BILL TO OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR FURTHER
DIRECTION, BUT FIRE SAFETY IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT FOR
OUR HOUSING STOCK ONCE IT'S
BUILT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
CAN ESCAPE AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR WHATEVER TO THIS
BILL, SEEING NONE IN THE ROOM?
OKAY LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAYS YEP. SENATOR GROUP. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ALLEN. I JUST WANT
TO TELL YOU, THANK YOU. I THINK
EVERY ONE OF US ESPECIALLY WITH
THE HYPE FIRES THAT WE HAD SINCE
WE'VE BEEN IN OFFICE. UH YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT SAFELY. UM I WATCHED A
VIDEO OF ONE OF THE TRUCKS
HAULING WATER TO ONE OF THE FIRE
AREAS AND IT WAS HORRENDOUS. IT
WAS LIKE DRIVING THROUGH A FIRE
TUNNEL. AND THAT WAS THE ONLY
EGRESS AND, UM TO GET INTO THAT
COMMUNITY AND GET OUT. AND I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE, UM THAT
HAPPENING, SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
BILL AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO. UM I WASN'T OPPOSED BECAUSE
BEFORE THE AMENDMENTS, I'M GOING
TO SIT AND WATCH IT BECAUSE YOU
ARE ALSO ANOTHER PERSON IN THE
BODY THAT I SERVED WITH THAT YOU
REALLY DO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
PEOPLE'S OPPOSITION AND WHY THEY
HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS, AND YOU
REALLY DO TRY TO WORK OUT THOSE
ISSUES. AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR
THAT, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
COMING TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU.
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU. UM I
AGREE ON THE PROBLEM THAT
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
IN AND IS AN UNBELIEVABLY MAJOR
ISSUE. I HAVE QUESTIONS ON TWO
PIECES OF THIS, AND THE FIRST
ONE IS THE PROCESS. BECAUSE I IF
I UNDERSTAND IT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS, AND THIS IS MOVING
VERY QUICKLY IN THIS FIRST TIME
WE'VE SEEN IT. IT IT WOULD
REQUIRE REPORT. HAVE THE
LEGISLATORS HAVE THERE BE SIX
MONTHS BEFORE THERE'S AN ACTION
IN THE LEGISLATURE COULD CHOOSE
TO GET INVOLVED IN THOSE SIX
MONTHS? THAT'S THE WAY IT'S
STRUCTURED. YEAH ON PAGE SIX OF
YOUR ANALYSIS, THAT'S THE
PROPOSAL FROM THEN WHY DIDN'T
YOU JUST HAVE IT COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE? BECAUSE MY
EXPERIENCE IS, IS THAT WHENEVER
YOU HAVE A CHANCE FOR THEM TO
COMMENT, NOBODY EVER COMMENTS
AND IT JUST IS A DEFACTO MOVE
AHEAD WITH THE PROCESS. WHY
WOULDN'T IT COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE? I'M HAPPY TO
CONSIDER HAVING A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE FROM FROM THE BOARD.
I THINK I THINK THE THOUGHT WAS
WE WANTED TO MOVE THIS PROCESS
FORWARD. WE WERE SO AWARE OF
WHAT IS NOT ENORMOUS CHALLENGE
WE HAVE IN THIS SPACE, AND WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WOULD YOU KNOW THAT THAT
WHATEVER EFFECTIVE RESPONSE
WOULD BE EXPEDITED, BUT IF WELL,
MY SECOND QUESTION MAY INFORM
THE FIRST ONE IN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS ON THE SUBSTANCE
BECAUSE THE IT SEEMS TO SAY
THERE'S A REPORT. OF COURSE,
RIGHT. I MEAN, I GET IT, BUT
THEY HAVE A LIFE OF THEIR OWN,
AND SO THE THING ABOUT IT IS, IS
IT IT'S A REPORT ON ON DOING A
PROCESS FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION. IS
THAT CORRECT? THAT'S RIGHT. HOW
DO YOU DEFINE NEW AND LET ME
GIVE THE CONTEXT FOR THE
QUESTION? BECAUSE THE REASON
THAT SOME OF THE THINGS BLEW UP
WITH THE PREVIOUS RULES AT THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY WAS MINIMUM
ARROWED WITCH AND IN THE SANTA
CRUZ MOUNTAINS. WHEN THERE WAS
THIS EASY, YOU FIRE IF, UH,
MINIMUM ROAD WIT HAD BEEN
REQUIRED FOR THE REBUILDING OF
THE HOUSES THAT HAD BURNED ABOUT
25% OF THEM WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO REBUILD. IT WOULD
HAVE ACTUALLY PUSHED PEOPLE OUT.
AND SO IT I CAN ENVISION, UM,
THE RESPONSE THAT WELL, THIS IS
JUST NEW. BUT WHAT IF THERE'S A
ONE NEW BUILDING ON A ROAD OF 12
HOUSES THAT NEED TO BE REBUILT?
AND THEN IT REQUIRES A THING
THAT CAN'T BE MET, AND IT'S A DE
FACTO NOT REBUILD FOR THE OTHER
12 HOUSES. HOW DO YOU GET IT
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE DOESN'T HAPPEN. I
MEAN, LOOK, YOU KNOW,
DEVELOPMENTS OVER A CERTAIN SIZE
IS REALLY ALWAYS BEEN OUR GOAL
HERE. NOT NOT JUST A SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES I, BUT IT'S STILL
CAPTURES THE SAME THING. AND YOU
SEE, THAT WAS THE CENTER OF THE
DEBATE. IN THE RULES IN FRONT OF
THE BOARD OF FOURTH STREET.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE WERE
UP IN ARMS BECAUSE IT WAS A
CHANGE THAT WAS GOING TO COME
AFTER A YEAR OR TWO AFTER THEIR
HOUSE BURNT DOWN, BUT THEY
HADN'T REBUILT IT AND THEY'VE
BEEN TAKING THESE STEPS AND THEY
HADN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET THERE
AND IT WAS GOING TO PUSH THEM
OUT. AND SO I THINK YOU KNOW THE
OTHER EXAMPLE THAT PROBABLY
MAKES THE POINT ON BOTH SIDES.
IS PARADISE AND WITH PARADISE
AND LORD KNOWS THEY NEED A
SEPARATE ROUTE. THEY NEED A
SECOND ROUTE IN AND OUT THAT WAS
WAS THE BIG THING. BUT IF UNDER
THE PRESCRIPTION OF THE BILL FOR
THE STUDY THERE'S ONE NEW. A
SAFEWAY OR SOMETHING IN THE
ENTIRE CITY. AND THEN THERE'S
15,000 HOUSES THAT ARE BEING
REBUILT. EVEN THOUGH THE 15,000
HOUSES DON'T COME UNDER THE NEW
THE ONES SAFEWAY DOES, AND IT
TRIGGERS IT FOR THE OTHER 15,000
HOUSES AND IN SOME INSTANCES, IF
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN ONCE AGAIN,
THERE'S A REBUILDING PROBLEM AND
SO AS MUCH AS IT SEEMS CLEAN TO
SAY NEW IT IS NOT CLEAN IN THE
ACTUAL PLACES WHERE THERE HAVE
BEEN FIRES AND THERE'S
REBUILDING STRUGGLES AND IN THE
SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS THERE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS HORRIFIC
SITUATION WHERE I DON'T KNOW
SOME VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
REBUILT AND THEN THE ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS HIT AND THEY FLOODED THE
ROADS CLOSED AND ALL THIS STUFF
HAPPENING NOW THERE THEY ALL
HAVE FEMA APPLICATIONS FOR TWO
DIFFERENT DISASTERS AND THE
PROCESS. DO WADE THE REBUILDING
IN A WAY THAT SOME OF THEM
COULDN'T GET IT DONE BEFORE THE
NEXT DISASTER HIT? AND SO I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS IS MOVING SO
QUICKLY THAT THERE'S UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVEN THOUGH I KNOW
IT'S BEEN MOVED TO A STUDY THAT
THE STUDY TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THESE THINGS AND DOESN'T SET UP
A SYSTEM OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN WHATEVER COMES
OUT THERE, AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A PLACE TO GO HERE TODAY
, BUT I REALLY WANTED TO PUT IT
FRONT AND CENTER BECAUSE FOR ME
YOU KNOW, I'M WILLING TO GIVE
YOU A COURTESY VOTE TO MOVE THIS
ALONG BECAUSE IT'S UNDER
DEADLINES, BUT IF THIS ISN'T
ADDRESSED IN SOME SIGNIFICANT
WAY WHEN IT COMES BACK, I'M
GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM. I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT, AND IT'S
CERTAINLY WE GOT. I AGREE.
THERE'S SOME AMBIGUITY HERE, UM,
IN THE SCENARIO THAT YOU RAISE,
AND SO IT'S A GOOD IT'S GOOD
DOING HELP TO INFORM HOW WE HOW
WE HONE THIS AND I WILL SAY, OF
COURSE. YOU KNOW, IT'S THOSE
AREAS WHERE WE'VE ALREADY HAD
DEMONSTRATED FIRE PROBLEM WHERE
WE PROBABLY MOST NEED. TO HAVE A
STRONG LOOK AT AT BETTER EGRESS.
UM AN INGRESS STANDARDS FOR
THOSE DEVELOPMENTS, UM. IT'S ONE
OBSERVATION, AND THAT'S THAT. I
DID A COMPARABLE BILL WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN WE WERE
DOING A FLOOD CONTROL PACKAGE,
AND THERE WAS ACTUALLY NO STATE
REQUIREMENT OR NO REQUIREMENT
WITH REGARD TO HAVE ACTUAL
EVACUATION AND SAFETY PLANS
RELATED TO LEVEES AND FLIGHTS.
AND SO, UM, I DID A BILL THAT
WAS NEGOTIATED ON BEHALF IRONIC
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE WONDERFUL
MOMENTS WHERE I'M DOING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER AND I CAN ONLY
GET DEMOCRATIC VOTES. IT WAS
LIKE, JUST REALLY A WONDERFUL
MOMENT. A AND YET THE ISSUE WAS
AT A GLOBAL LEVEL. CAN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE GROUND IN
EACH AREA? DO A SAFETY PLAN.
THAT REALLY MEETS THEIR LOCAL
NEEDS AND MAKE SURE THAT IF
THERE IS A FLOOD EMERGENCY THERE
ARE EVACUATION ROUTES THERE AND
THAT ALL THIS CONVERSATION HAS
HAPPENED BEFORE YOU'RE IN THE
EMERGENCY, SO I WOULD JUST ASK
THAT YOU TAKE THIS INTO ACCOUNT
BECAUSE I ALREADY HAVE
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE ALERTED TO
THIS AND ARE ARE CONCERNED AND
THE ONE LAST ANECDOTE I WOULD
SAY IS WHEN WE WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DROUGHT IN 2011 TO
2015. WE HAD WATER SYSTEMS IN
THIS AREA DRYING UP. AND SO MARK
GHILARDUCCI AND I LEADER TOUR.
BECAUSE WE HAD TO BUILD A FOUR
MILE PIPE OVER THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS TO HOOK ONE WATER
DISTRICT UP WITH ANOTHER, SO IT
WOULDN'T GO DRY IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND WE'RE GOING UP
THESE ROADS AND MARKKULA. DUTY
BRINGS THREE HUGE HONKING SUVS
THAT ROOS SUVS. WE GO UP THIS
ROAD WHERE REDWOOD TREES ARE THE
SHOULDER IN SOME PLACES, THERE'S
JUST ENOUGH WITH FOR THE CAR.
AND WE HAD TO LUZ RIVAS TURN
INTO A DRIVEWAY BACK UP AND
REVERSE ORDER TO GET OUT. AND I
SAID TO HIM, JUST F Y I YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIS IN A WATER ISSUE
. IT'S GONNA BURN HERE AT SOME
POINT AND THE EXACT SAME ISSUE
OF INGRESS AND EGRESS ARE GOING
TO BE REMEMBER THIS MOMENT AND
REMEMBER HOW WIDE THIS IS AND
HOW IT IS. AND SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS THE REASON
EVERYTHING GOT REALLY
CONTROVERSIAL AND BOGGED DOWN AT
THE BOARD OF FOURTH STREET,
WHERE THESE PRACTICAL DETAILS SO
ANYWAY, ENOUGH, BUT I FEEL LIKE
YOU'VE SAID YOU'LL CONSIDER THIS
GOING. ABSOLUTELY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING ALL THIS
UP AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON AND I AGREE. THERE'S
A CERTAIN DEGREE OF AMBIGUITY
HERE WITH REGARDS TO THE
DEFINITION OF NEW DEVELOPMENT,
AND THIS WAS LANGUAGE THAT WAS
GIVEN TO US BY THE BY THE
COMMITTEE, BUT BUT I BUT, YOU
KNOW AND QUITE FRANKLY, I THINK
THERE'S SOME THERE'S SOME.
THERE'S A OPEN QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHERE WE OUGHT TO GO ON. UH YOU
KNOW, WITH THAT DEFINITION, SO,
SO LET'S LET'S WORK TOGETHER ON
TRYING TO HONE IT, AND THERE'S
OPEN QUESTIONS. BUT IF 25% OF
THE PEOPLE AFTER A FIRE CAN'T
REBUILD THEIR HOUSES, I WANT YOU
RIGHT NEXT TO ME AT THE PUBLIC
HEARING. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
IT'S NOT ABOUT MAKING SURE THEY
DON'T. THEY CAN'T READ. WELL
YEAH, WE'VE AIRED THIS. WE'RE
GOOD. THANK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN.
SENATOR STERN HAS A QUESTION OR
COMMENT. YEAH I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
UM, I WAS TO BE FRANK. A LITTLE.
I GUESS, UH, DISAPPOINTED THAT,
UM, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A TWO
STEP OR MAYBE A THREE STEP NOW.
IF WE HAVE TO, THEN HAVE A LOOK
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. I A I
THINK THE LACK OF LEADERSHIP ON
THEIR RISK IN FIRE ZONES AROUND
THE PUSH FOR VERY HIGH VALUE
LAND FROM SPECULATIVE DEVELOPERS
WHO WANT TO BUILD BIG FANCY LOTS
AND DO THINGS UM, THAT AREN'T
THAT AREN'T YOU KNOW? MY HIGH
SCHOOL NURSE WHOSE HOME BURNED
DOWN IN WOLSEY OR MY OWN PLACE
THAT BURNT DOWN OR THOMAS OR ALL
THESE FIRES HAVE BEEN THROUGH IN
THOSE SORT OF THOSE HEART
WRENCHING STORIES, BUT INSTEAD,
SOME SORT OF PROXY FOR PUNCHING
A HOLE RIGHT INTO LIKE VERY HIGH
VALUE LAND WHERE THERE'S A
THERE'S A LOT OF, UH GAIN TO BE
HAD, AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
NECESSARILY SOMETHING THAT IS
GONNA GO HELP REAL WORKING
PEOPLE. YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
EFFORTS AT THE BORDER FORESTRY,
THANKFULLY, DECIDED NOT TO MOVE
ON. UM THAT INFORMED THIS BILL
AND THIS WHOLE ARENA AND IT'S
STUFF WHERE, YOU KNOW, OKAY
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF BETTER
FIRE SAFETY IN INGRESS AND
EGRESS. HOW ABOUT WE JUST TAKE
THAT FIRE ROAD OR THAT DEAD END
AND MAKE IT INTO UH YOU KNOW, 25
NEW MCMANSIONS. THAT'S THAT'S
HOUSING, AND THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN
SAY THAT'S RESILIENT OR 1 TO
25,000 UNITS. UM THOSE DECISIONS
ARE GETTING MADE RIGHT NOW. I
MEAN, THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY ON THE LINE FOR THOSE
DECISIONS TO GET MADE, SO
SOMEBODY HAS TO PUMP THE BRAKES
HERE AND AT LEAST LOOK AT RISK.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOUR BILL I
MEAN, NOW IT'S A NOW IT'S JUST
SAYING GO STUDY. IT'S FOR
POTENTIAL INCLUSION, WHICH I'M
NOT THRILLED ABOUT, UM, BECAUSE
I THINK IF LEADERSHIP DOESN'T
COME FROM THE LEGISLATURE, THIS
INSURANCE CRISIS IS GOING TO EAT
THE WHOLE STATE ALIVE AND I WE
CAN TELL OURSELVES IT'S NOT A
PROBLEM AND THAT WE CAN KIND OF
JUST KEEP DOING HOW WE'RE DOING
OR CHIP AWAY AT IT. BUT UM
PEOPLE GONNA GO BANKRUPT ON IT,
AND THIS AND IT'S GOING TO EMPTY
OUT TO ALL THE NON FIRE AREAS,
TOO, BECAUSE IF WE BREAK THE
INSURANCE MARKET IN CALIFORNIA,
BECAUSE WE'RE SO BUSY TRYING TO
LIKE IGNORE RISK WHERE THERE IS
RISK. OR FORCE THEM TO IGNORE
RISK WITH HIS RISK. OR WRITE A
POLICY HERE WHERE YOU ACTUALLY
AND THIS IS, BY THE WAY, MY
FOLKS, RIGHT THIS IS MY THESE
ARE MY HOME TOWNS LIKE THIS IS
WHERE I REPRESENT. SO THESE ARE
HARD TRUTHS. BUT IF WE DON'T DO
THAT STUFF FROM THE STATE LEVEL,
THEN IT ENDS UP BEING A GIANT
SUBSIDY TO SOME KIND OF THING
THAT REALLY JUST TRIES TO IGNORE
WHAT CLIMATE IS DOING TO US, SO
IT'S A REALLY HARD PROBLEM TO
SOLVE. I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE A
SHOT AT THIS, UM, AT LEAST TO
GET SOME PROCESS GOING TO BORDER
FOURTH STREET. I WANT TO COMMEND
THE BOARD FOR BEING DELIBERATE
ABOUT THIS WORK AND FOR SWEATING
THOSE DETAILS, AND I HOPE THEY
KEEP DOING THAT. BUT I THINK I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE NOT JUST
IN THIS BILL, BUT IN GENERAL IS
GOING TO HAVE TO REALLY STEP UP
AND WRESTLE WITH HARD THINGS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF US IN FIRE
ZONES. YEAH THANK YOU. LISTEN, I
AGREE WITH YOU, SENATOR. I AM
OBVIOUSLY HAD A MORE AMBITIOUS
BILL IS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED, AND
WE SCALE IT BAG. I DO WANT TO
RECOMMEND YOU ALSO FOR YOUR WORK
ON SP 63. AND SOME OF THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THIS SPACE,
UM YOU KNOW, I LOOK AT THE END
OF THE DAY. I THINK WE GOT WE
GOT DEEP INTO A REBUILD
CONVERSATION. MAYBE WHAT WE
OUGHT TO DO IS JUST GRANDFATHER
AND THE EXISTING STUFF. BUT
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NEW
CONSTRUCTION, TRULY NEW
DEVELOPMENT. WE JUST GOT TO BE
SMARTER ABOUT ABOUT ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE ALLOWING. I THINK I MEAN,
OF COURSE, THE BILLS MUCH MORE
NARROW, AND IT'S JUST GOING TO
STUDY THIS STUFF AND LOOK AT
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES. BUT THANK
YOU, SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, SENATOR DOLLY! SO AS
ALWAYS, YOU DO GOOD WORK. AND I,
UH, WANTED TO JUST KIND OF
MAYBE. SPRINGBOARD OFF OF A
SENATOR LAIRD. SO THE DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS AND SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTED PARADISE WHO
ACTUALLY DID IT AND ACCESS
BEFORE PARADISE FIRE. WE DID A
BILL TO ACTUALLY HELP ACCESS.
THE PROBLEM WAS PEOPLE DIDN'T
KNOW TO GO THAT WAY. DURING THE
FIRE. WE ACTUALLY DID A BILL TO
WIDEN OUT. AND ACTUALLY GET AN
ACCESS OUT. UM PRIOR TO THE
PARADISE FIRE, BUT WE HAD NO WAY
TO COMMUNICATE IT IN REAL TIME.
AND WE DID, UH, SINCE THEN,
WE'VE DONE A LOT WITH THE 911
SYSTEM. WE'VE WE'RE TRYING TO
COME AROUND THESE NATURAL DATA.
SO YOU HAVE FIRE IS WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE, BUT FLOOD IS
ANOTHER ONE, WHICH I KNOW
SENATOR STERN AND MANY OTHERS
HAVE HAD THOSE ISSUES.
TYPICALLY, AFTER A FIRE WE HAVE
EVEN MORE EXPOSURE. SO FOR ME,
I'M GONNA LAY OFF THE BILL. I
THINK THERE IS SOME WORK HERE
DOING THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND YOU TALK ABOUT
UM AND SOMEBODY WHO SAT 16 YEARS
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND,
YOU KNOW, THANK GOD. I DON'T SEE
ANOTHER DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
THOSE ARE VERY CONTENTIOUS.
THERE ALSO, UM AND PREVIOUS
BOARDS DO THINGS AND PREVIOUS
LEGISLATURES AND THERE'S AND IT
PUTS bIN
HAVE A PARADISE WHERE WE HAD
GROWTH. NOT VERY WELL MANAGED.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT, BUT IT TOOK
35 YEARS TO DO THAT. YOU DON'T
FIX THAT WITH ONE BILL, OR WITH
ONE AND THEN WHEN YOU HAVE A
FIRE, YOU HAVE REBUILDING ISSUES
WHICH I HAVE FACED WITH, UM NOT
ONLY IN PARADISE, BUT IN SHASTA,
WHERE WE'VE HAD LOTS OF HOMES
DAMAGED. SO THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS. WE WANT TO GET THIS
RIGHT. I THINK YOU'RE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK TO GET IT RIGHT. BUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
RIGHT AND THAT WE GIVE SOME
ABILITY FOR GOOD COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PAST. TO BE ABLE TO BE MANAGED
IN A WAY THAT IS MORE SAFE SO WE
CAN HAVE THOSE INSURANCE RATES
GO DOWN. AND AFTER A FIGHT. THIS
IS AFTER A FIRE OR AFTER A FLOOD
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO REBUILD
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE THEIR WHOLE
LIFE INVESTMENT, AND IT'S GONE.
AND THEN THE RULES COME IN AND
SAY, OH, YOU CAN'T DO ALL THESE
THINGS AND TRUST ME. WHAT
SENATOR LARGE TALKING ABOUT. I
HEAR EVERY DAY FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO
JUST LIVE A NORMAL LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO IS DICEY. THIS IS
A TOUGH AREA, BUT I THINK YOU'RE
MOVING THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT
THE DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS AND
WE NEED TO GET IT RIGHT. AND THE
BORDER FORESTRY. HAS BEEN, UM,
PUT ON THE SPOT, QUITE FRANKLY,
TO TRY TO FIX ALL THESE THINGS
THAT HAPPENED OVER DECADES AND
I'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER FORESTRY
AND I'VE TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF
THEM, AND I'VE HELPED GET PEOPLE
APPOINTED TO IT BECAUSE IT IS A
TOUGH JOB TO DO AND WE WANT TO
DO IT RIGHT. SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT BECAUSE I THINK THERE
IS, UM WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM
THIS COMMITTEE AND WHY THE BILL
IS TOUGH IS BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF DETAIL THAT NEEDS TO BE
IN HERE. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SHARON DOLLY, SENATOR
SEYARTO TÔI THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND UM SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY. UM
ONE OF THE PERSPECTIVE I HAVE IS
MAYBE DIFFERENT FROM OTHERS. BUT
WATCHING OVER THE YEARS IS OUR
FIRE ISSUES HAVE EVOLVED TO A
DIFFERENT LEVEL THAN THEY HAVE.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT EQUIPMENT
ISSUES. WE HAVE BIGGER, LARGER
EQUIPMENT THAT WE BRING IN AND A
LOT OF TIMES THAT COMPETES WITH
THESE INGRESS EGRESS ISSUES. AND
WE DEVELOPED COMMUNITIES IN
AREAS AND FRANKLY, THAT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT THEY WERE
CONSIDERING WHEN THEY DID IT.
AND AS WE HAVE MORE OF THESE
FIRES THAT WE AS WE HAVE MORE OF
THESE TYPES OF DISASTERS, WE
NEED TO LEARN FROM THOSE AND
THAT LEARNING IS ALL ABOUT
KEEPING PEOPLE ALIVE IN THE
FUTURE. AND SO IT KIND OF
TRANSCENDS WHETHER IT'S A BRAND
NEW DEVELOPMENT OR YOU BURN DOWN
A TOWN AND THEN REBUILD THE TOWN
. BUT AT THE SAME TIME AS MY
COLLEAGUE WAS STATING, WE DON'T
WANT IT TO TURN INTO THIS GIANT
BUREAUCRACY WHERE PEOPLE ARE NOW
DISPLACED FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS WHILE WE TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO, OR
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING. AND
INCREASING COST BURDENS ON THEM.
UM BUT INGRESS AND EGRESS IS AN
EXTREMELY PART EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PART. OF ANY COMMUNITY
PLANNING TO KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE IN
DISASTER. AND WHILE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S SOME, YOU KNOW ISSUES
WITHIN THIS THAT OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE EXPRESSED WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND TRY
TO FIND THAT SWEET SPOT WHERE
WE'RE ADDRESSING THAT GOING
FORWARD FOR EVERYBODY. YOU KNOW,
I IF I'M IF I BUILD A HOUSE, AND
IT SUFFERS A DISASTER PERSONALLY
, I'M PROBABLY GOING TO LOOK AT
WHAT I DID BEFORE AND DO THINGS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THE NEXT TIME
UM, BECAUSE I WANT I WANTED TO
SURVIVE THE NEXT TIME. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
UM IN IN IN BILLS LIKE YOURS, I
BELIEVE IS TO MAKE SURE IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN LIKE THAT AGAIN.
UM AND THEN WE GIVE PEOPLE A
CHANCE. AND SO, UM, UM YOU KNOW,
I HOPE WE CAN FIND THAT SWEET
SPOT WHERE WE DON'T OVER
BUREAUCRATIZED THE PROCESS OF
RECOVERY BECAUSE THAT'S A HUGE
ORDEAL FOR PEOPLE, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE DON'T BUILD EXACTLY
WHAT GOT THEM THERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. AND UH AND SO, WITH THAT
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL AND
APPRECIATE MOVE ALONG. MAYBE
WORKING WITH US A LITTLE BIT.
SEE THOSE PERSPECTIVES
ESPECIALLY RELATES TO THE HOW
THINGS HAVE EVOLVED IN THE FIRE
SERVICE EQUIPMENT HAS SO MUCH
BIGGER HOW OUR RESPONSES HAVE SO
MANY MORE. VEHICLES ETCETERA
GOING IN AND A LOT OF TIMES.
THAT IN ITSELF IS WHAT HAPPENS
IS THEY LOCK UP THE ENGINE OR
THE ROADWAYS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
WIDE ENOUGH TO GET PEOPLE OUT
BECAUSE YOU'RE TRYING TO GET IN.
AND SO ANYWAY, APPRECIATE THE
BILL, AND LIKE I SAID, WE'LL BE
SUPPORTING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SOON. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR WE DO NOT HAVE EMOTION
YET. CENTER LAIRD MOVES THE
BILL. ANYONE ELSE WANT TO SPEAK
UP? ALRIGHT I'LL JUST SAY THAT
THIS IS A TOP ERODING BILL.
OBVIOUSLY I REPRESENT THE 37
SENATE-DISTRICT IN ORANGE
COUNTY, AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY AN
ISSUE THAT AFFECTS MY COMMUNITY
AS WELL. I THINK WE'RE ONE OF
THE FASTEST GROWING COMMUNITIES
IN THE COUNTRY, AND A LOT OF
THAT BUILDING IS OCCURRING AND
VERY FIRE PRONE AREAS. THE ISSUE
OF INGRESS EGRESS IS CRITICAL
ONE AND AS YOUR BILL, YOUR BILL
REALLY IDENTIFIES A PROBLEM THAT
WE NEEDED TO SOLVE. AND UM, I
THINK THE WITNESS WHO SAID THIS
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS, I THINK
DESCRIBED THIS ACCURATELY. I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH FOLKS AND I WANT TO
THANK MY STAFF FOR REALLY, I
THINK HELPING THIS BILL MOVE
ALONG WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THEY SUGGESTED IN ROAD. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
STAFF AND WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
WITH THAT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YOU KNOW, I WANT TO. I
JUST WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THE VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
MEANINGFUL, VERY SUBSTANTIVE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE HAD. I
THINK EVERYONE'S BROUGHT UP. UM
YOU ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
TRYING TO DO HERE WITH THIS BILL
? CLEARLY UM, ALSO UNDERSTOOD
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO DO WITH THE
PREVIOUS VERSION, BUT WHERE WE
ARE NOW, UH AND I THINK EVERYONE
HAS GRASPED IT REALLY, REALLY
WELL, AND I IF ANYTHING, WE YOU
KNOW, AS YOU SAY, THE DEVIL IS
IN THE DETAILS. THERE'S A LOT OF
THERE'S A LOT OF A NUMBER OF
THINGS WE NEED TO WORK OUT HERE,
BUT ULTIMATELY THIS IS REALLY
COMES DOWN TO WHAT SENATORS, THE
ARTIST SAID, WHICH IS ABOUT
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY FOR
US TO NOT REPEAT THE SAME
MISTAKES OF THE PAST AND GROWING
UP IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY. AND
IT'S WITHIN THAT SPIRIT THAT I
RESPECT FOR ASTRONAUT VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LARRY. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS MEN, MEN. I
SEYARTO HØI ALLEN. I BECKER
BECKER. I DOLLY. GROVE. HER
TAITO HER TITLE. I LAIRD LAIRD.
I LIMÓN PADILLA. PADILLA I STERN
STERN. AYE. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
OKAY THE VOTE IS 80 WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL. AH AND I THINK
WE'RE STILL WAITING ON ONE MORE
MEMBER. BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN UP THE ROLES ON OUR
PREVIOUS TWO BILLS. UM LET'S GO
BACK TO SP 689 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THAT. SP 689. THE MOTION
IS DUE PAST THE TRANSPORTATION
AND THE CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 1
WITH CHAIR VOTING I CENTER
SEYARTO. I DON'T KNOW. DELI.
DOLLY! NO! HER TATO TATO, I
LIMÓN. STERN STERN. AYE. THREE.
THE VOTE IS 7 TO 3 WILL LEAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL FOR THE MOMENT
. LET'S GO TO SB 559 BY SENATOR
MEN. A MOTION HERE IS DO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HER TAITO. LIMÓN STERN.
MR SP 559 I STERN? AYE. 63 THE
VOTE COUNT ON THAT IS 63 AND
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR SENATOR
LIMÓN. UH AND I THINK WE'RE JUST
WAITING ON SENATOR LIMÓN AT THIS
POINT, RIGHT? YEAH. UM YEP. SO
WE'LL TAKE A RECESS AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
HEARING SO WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
UP THE ROLE AGAIN. UM AND WE'LL
START WITH SB 689 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO TRANSPORTATION
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RIGHT THE CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO
3. AYE, SENATORS. LIMÓN LIMÓN,
AYE. THE VOTE IS 83 THAT BILL IS
OUT. LET'S MOVE ON TO SP 559 BY
SENATOR MEN. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 3
WHEELCHAIR VOTING I AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO CENTER, HER
TAITO CENTER LIMÓN. AYE. THE
VOTE ON THAT IS 73. THE BILL IS
OUT. FINALLY, LET'S MOVE TO SP
571 BY SENATOR ALLEN. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS. ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL RIGHT. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 80. WITH CHAIR
VOTING I AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR DELI, SENATOR
GROVE. SENATOR LIMÓN LIMÓN, AYE.
THAT VOTE IS 90. THE BILL IS
OUT. UM AND WITH THAT WE'RE
DONE. THANK YOU, EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION.
WE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.